[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
going through your answers to the
question that we posed to you which was
what's the scariest situation that
you've ever been in
so i mean you know it's just that time
of the year
when uh spooky spooky i mean personally
it's always that time of the year for me
i'm always willing to be scared and i
don't think that we should just
limit horror and darkness to just one
day a year it seems dumb to me let's
open it up to
the entire year and i think that's
happening i think a lot of people are
like
if you got a horror movie it doesn't
have to come out in the fall anymore it
could come out in january and people are
happy you know what i'm gonna
i want i'm gonna make you eat your words
i think by the end of this conversation
because
i think we're not just going to be
talking about entertaining
getting scared for the sake of the
thrill by the end of this conversation i
finally intend to be talking about
have either one of us ever seen a ghost
do we believe
friends and you think they claim that
they haven't seen a ghost
and is that something that i have seen a
ghost
and do you want do you really want to
experience
that type of speech well like i'm not
goes honest i'm not going to answer that
question directly right now but what i
will say is i do find it interesting
that you see a a what appears to be
a very very dark and broad
demarcation between real scary stuff
and entertainment whereas i see them as
being
exactly in the same boat okay yeah and
i'm gonna call you on that because i
can't just because it's negative and
scary i can't believe that's true just
because i fear for my life doesn't mean
it's not
entertaining it's just different kind of
entertainment listen
it's all fun and games and beavers until
somebody sees
a crouching dark angel in their
fireplace okay
that's all i'm saying and that's what
we're going to talk about
eventually if you have the guts to stick
around
i do want to i do have a question for
you
if you're in conversation whatever the
context
and you want to say essentially
let's zero in on this particular subject
here let's
get a little bit closer what phrase
might you use
to say that are you are you asking me
because you want to know or are you
framing me because you think i'm wrong
well we were in a meeting earlier today
right and i this is i don't i'm this
isn't like honestly
this isn't a pet peeve of mine like i
don't really care
but it hit me that i know someone else
said it and then you said it and i was
like oh and we said the same thing and
you both said it the same way which
i believe is technically incorrect again
i don't i think i would say
and i think i did say i want to hone in
on this thing and i believe that and i
know
you say home in and i think that most
people say hone in
but and i said hone in for a really long
time until
i don't know who it was somebody pointed
out that that's not correct
it's home and yeah so if you honed
something that's like sharpening
something like
you want to sharpen that and you would
never you don't hone in on anything yeah
if you
honed something you bring it down to a
sharp point
yeah you you hone into one particular
detail
yeah so visually it works if i'm going
to hone in on something
that's not that's not what you're
thinking is this going to get spooky or
are you just is this another
conversation it's just a different
conversation okay
uh but like a home in like what would
that mean it's like
beacon a homing pigeon gets goes to a
location so if you want to home
you home in on something now i'm not
saying that technically you only home in
on your home
but you can hone in on anything that can
come to a point
well but is that how you're actually
seeing it when you say phone in
absolutely that's how i see it
you're saying you when you say hone in
picture you picture
that something getting sharper yeah and
that's that's
and i you know what i think i'm wrong
but i think i'm actually
in a more defensible position and it
should be changed dictionary.com
who's in charge of this now um society
man well that's the thing is that words
here's here's the reason that i don't
that i wanted to talk about it but i
also don't have strong
feelings about it because words because
you could be wrong
j well i know that i i think that i am
technically according to the english
language i think that i'm right but what
i'm getting at
is the english language is just a in all
language is just a representation
of some principle so it's not really an
exact science
hmm writer's digest.com the verb home
means to sharper to make more cute yeah
we knew that
as in honing a talent yes you don't hone
in a talent
in a verb form home as to home in on
means to move
or be aimed toward a destination or
target with great accuracy
and that's what isil's home in on
targets yeah so if i want to home in on
a subject you're correct
but you're to focus you just not get the
spirit of your answer is not right
that's not true i'm just saying so if
you do find yourself in a situation
where you're interacting with like like
if you're at a job interview
it is but there is potentially a
scenario you wouldn't hire somebody who
said hold
in no i wouldn't but what i'm saying is
you might be in an interview with
someone who cares about that especially
if like you're in
an interview for like a to be like a
writer's assistant or something that
where
your command of the english language is
really important and
there may be somebody out there who
interviews people and if they say hone
in they choose not to hire them i'm just
trying to look out for everybody
i mean i appreciate your demands of it
merriam-webster
is honed wrong the verb hone also dates
to the 1700s
just like home uh its original meaning
is to sharpen the smooth with a wet
stone by the early
20s 20th century another meaning had
developed to make more acute
intense or effective instead of just
honing blades people
were now honing skills yeah you can hone
a skill
it's the narrowing or sharpening of
focus but can you imply
in a skill it's the narrowing or
sharpening of focus
implied in the figurative meaning of
home that seems to have made
hone in seem like the right phrase to
some rather than home in
uh the use of hone in dates to around
1965 which means
only about 10 years newer than the
figurative use of home in
we have enough evidence of hone in in
use that we
enter it in our dictionaries as the note
at the entry makes clear however
home in remains significantly more
common
and is the version to use if you want to
avoid criticism so this is
what i'm saying 0n is also an option if
you want to avoid
the similar h words altogether yeah i'm
gonna
look let's zero in on this i'm just
gonna say zero in from now on because i
don't wanna have this conversation ever
again
let's get the 50 000 foot view of this
that's another thing that
five thousand foot or it's two thousand
no one says the same number but i
believe
fifty thousand grand that ten thousand
or fifty thousand are the
acceptable answers five thousand is too
close
i'd rather get spooky than open up
another merriam-webster
debate all right let's read the first uh
answer to our question
from haley who says swiftly mythical
so i love halloween costumes decorations
scary movies
everything can i jump in here and say
i halloween's really hurting this year
yeah i mean
i don't i mean my kids were talking
about costumes a few weeks ago
and then i never heard anything else
about it because i think it dawned on
them that like
we ain't going to dress up at home yeah
it's not happening for us do a show for
each other
i'm sure it's happening for some people
but it ain't happening for us the people
i feel most sorry for the
people who uh it's not the
trick-or-treaters i mean it's the people
who
go all out and make their houses
incredible for everyone to
enjoy and i think they may still do that
the thing about
i'm seeing decorations you can like just
drive by it i was really starting to
enjoy halloween like last halloween was
the first halloween that
you know because britain was living with
me and he's so obsessed with halloween
and he really connected with you and
your love of halloween
he he goes to all of those uh
haunted houses and scary zones and you
know
scary zones he started taking me and
lillian lincoln to some of those like
you and
uh locked with with us to universal
studios last year
and i start i started to get how much
fun it can be like we had a blast
all the stuff that happened in those few
nights that we spent it like the
the horror night places that we went
last year would come up in conversation
and we would just laugh our heads off
man
and it's fun i'm like you know what i'm
starting to get it
but now and then this year i get it if
you're not into some drive-through car
type haunted situation that you got to
buy a ticket what is happening yeah
then i'm just along with most anything
else i'm skipping out so
well and there's a question haley
halloween almost
is it is a gap in these haunted houses
gonna throw it off so they don't do it
next year you know what i'm saying like
no some people may not be back with a
vengeance i hope they will
uh okay about two years ago i was
preparing for a costume
and i had this moldable plastic that
turned squishy when submerged in hot
water and hardened when it dried
i thought it would be perfect to make
some fake teeth
there are even tutorials for it on
youtube so i felt pretty safe doing it
however
i missed a very big disclaimer do not
use said technique
if you have braces and guess what i have
braces i slathered the sticky plastic
all over my top teeth and waited for it
to dry
it was thick so at what point did it
dawn on hayley that this was dumb
when i decided to take it off it
hardened and connected
in between my braces wire oh god it was
like a bug in amber
this [ __ ] was not coming off
i had to pour 150 degree water in my
mouth
to get it somewhere again 150 degrees i
mean did you have a thermometer
you may have thought it was hot but 150
degrees
if we're questioning if we're picking
this story apart i don't know what we're
going to do when we get to the ghost
stories
i thought my braces were going to be
ruined and my teeth were going to break
out of my mouth i was sweating and
crying and shaking for at least 20
minutes before the plastic came out and
everything was
okay spoiler alert my teeth were loose
for a few hours
of the story don't skip disclaimer i
mean i definitely relate to
a skipping over disclaimers and doing
something impulsive and stupid
i mean it's that feeling you get when
you put your head between
the the railing trains no
no when you're a kid and you put you
you're like you can't look over the
railing so you just stick your head
between the two spokes of the railing
that protects you from something so you
get a better view of it
and then all of a sudden you realize you
can't get your head back
out right or that i mean even as an
adult
i've taken a ring and i've put it on the
wrong finger
and i've smushed it all the way down and
then realized i can't get it back over
my knuckle
and there's this feeling of i'm gonna
have to go
it's like you know it's that wave that
comes over your whole body
that's like oh my god i'm going to
they're going to have to call firemen
i don't you know i'm going to i'm going
to be on a tick tock but i think the
thing is is that with the ring thing
which definitely has happened to me
especially like you put it on a
different hand
and linear like uh i started wearing
this like fit
fitness ring and if i put it on my if
actually if i like go on a long walk at
night my hand will kind of swell up
but i don't panic anymore because i'm
like i can get soap and water
but like you think about the people
going to the er and if you know an er
doctor you've heard all the stories it's
usually something that you've stuck up
your rear end
that is is like the most embarrassing
stories
so i just feel like as long as you don't
stick
with strange things up your rear end
yeah you're probably going to be okay
you're probably not going to be too
embarrassed
okay i'm really really i'm really trying
to like
you shouldn't be sending that home you
shouldn't be like really yeah
really zero a ring or even like head
through the banister i mean all those
are situations didn't you
did one of your kids get his head caught
in the banister i mean probably
my kids have gotten caught i know i i
distinctively remember
shepard i'm pretty sure it was shepherd
getting his head caught in a banister
it seems very familiar but i don't
remember the story it's very on
character
on brand yeah yeah i hate that moment
man i experienced that moment too
much the wave of
stupidity just washing over me i should
not have done that
um scary this is uh yeah that's scary
but it's uh
you know it's not there's no demons
yet all right fine i i got some demons
for you
let's keep going we got another one but
first we want to encourage you to go to
mythical.com
okay because that's the place that has
all the stuff so you can rep your boys
what you looking for
don't you have like something you're
gonna hold up oh yeah you mean this
you mean this fine fine hoodie
embroidered
to perfection look at that
i'm gonna put my and put my hand in it
so it looks like it's
being it's being worn by a ghost uh we
would be wearing that but it continues
to be unseasonably warm
here and uh neither of us wanted to put
a hoodie on
uh but maybe where you're at hoodies or
you know oh yeah you need a hoodie
appropriate at this point
this one's embroidered 3d embroidery
i've got all the bean shirt i don't even
know if that's still being sold
no way it is being sold but i don't know
if it's sold out but you know it's also
at mythical.com there's lots of things
at mythical.com
rep your boys think about us when
clothing rubs against you be all the
time really
all right next question or next answer
nicole bersie tweeted at us oh this
this is a this is a note that's been
tweeted
so buckle in my first real
vacay first plane trip i went to cuba
with my boyfriend
during dinner out of nowhere he slumped
over on the table
and fell to the floor oh my god dragging
the tablecloth
and dishes with him he made it dramatic
i was sure he was dead my future flashed
before my eyes i immediately saw myself
having to fly home alone
and to tell his family the waiters
picked him up and carried him away
me running behind some older gentleman
said put him down
and threw a pitcher of ice water on his
head
and he woke up like a cartoon he woke up
it turns out he hiccuped
and it gave him a weird pain and he just
fainted
i had never seen someone faint before so
you
nicole girl you've never been on
vacation
you've never been on a plane trip you
never okay i can understand that but
you've never seen somebody faint before
she's lived a sheltered life but even if
you have seen someone faint before
this scenario i wouldn't i would be
thinking like
choking i mean but just like dropping
dead i would be thinking heart attacks
or like aneurysm or something yeah and
you're very scared
but she had never seen someone faint
before apparently it's a thing in his
family
i was up all night waking him up and
he's like i promise i'm not gonna die
can you stop waking me up so anyway
we've been together for 21 years now
and when my son fainted earlier this
year
i didn't think he was dead so that's
progress
now it's like a goat it's like one of
those goats
the family has goat fainting goat jeans
i've seen someone faint and the most
memorable
uh fainting experience was uh when will
thomas
fainted in the front row of chorus when
we were like at a
like at lillington like we went to the
other school and he like fell in the
front i wasn't in christmas
coral ensemble um he was the first of i
think three people this
le it's an urban legend that multiple
people fainted that day but he fell
he was on the front row and had no one
to catch him so he fell straight down
like
a like like a stack of bricks just
like a tower falling like his nose hit
him first
he did not catch himself yeah that and
the fact that other people fainted right
after that is what is so crazy
don't lock your knees but i've fainted
three two singing
three times in my life that i can
remember the first time was when i got
the news about my
herniated discs in the doctor's office
i've told that story before the second
time was when i went to get
shots in my back for my herniated discs
and they uh hooked me up to an iv
and usually the blood thing in the iv
thing is not a big deal
and i was alright i was sitting in a
wheelchair because they were wheeling me
to the
to the operating room and they like put
this thing in my arm and i just like
went
and just fainted and it was just like i
was i didn't i didn't think i was scared
did they pour uh cold water on you nope
no
and i immediately woke up and i think
again i didn't tell anybody you didn't
tell anybody
uh and then the third time i just fell
asleep for a second oh i'm sleepy today
you were present for uh when
we were kind of on like a little mini
getaway
with some friends yeah we were hanging
out with friends and our wives were
there
and i i was not feeling well yeah i
noticed that you were sitting on the
couch for a long time you're quiet
i was like man we're having a good time
why is that so quiet i was and that's
in a bit green i wasn't feeling well and
then like jessie looks up and she's like
you don't
you don't look when i was like yeah i
think i need to just go lay down in the
back
like leave this conversation and go like
lay down in the background and it's one
of those things where you were talking
to jesse but everybody stopped and heard
you say yeah i think i i think i need to
go lay down it's like
it's such a strange thing for you to say
you know
but it's not i mean you're wearing a
green hat you weren't that green
but like the the i look the light
spilling off of your very green hat onto
your face
i'd lost my color you would you
literally had turned a little bit green
and so i stood up
to walk uh across like
like across the living room and kitchen
into the back area of the house where i
was gonna lay down
and the next thing i remember we're all
seated the next thing i remember you can
tell me your perspective in a second but
the next thing i remember
is waking up and when you wake up
like when you've really fainted yeah you
wake up and actually so i've actually
fainted more than three times because i
did that stupid thing in high school or
middle school where you made each other
faint which you shouldn't do but we did
it all the time
um and i just remember you see like a
pinpoint of light that slowly gets
bigger
and it got a little bit bigger and the
the space
which was surrounded by blackness was
filled with your wife's face
just christy's face yeah you were having
an angelic vision i was like
what is happening and then the circle
got a little bit long
wider and there was my wife's face yeah
behind
what and then it got wider and wider and
then i and like it took me
it took me a good while to really get
back to
yo yeah dude like oh you fainted you got
up
so what did you see well you got up
and you took a step and the best i can
recall
everyone was seated watching you and
then
i mean you're so freaking tall i just
didn't know like
is that how he gets up i've never really
noticed that he's like swaying
afterwards
never really watched him get up he sways
like a tree when he gets up
yeah and you'd say you didn't feel good
so i was like watching
and then it's like it it was
as if you were in you were stepping in
quicksand
and you took an is but really what had
happened you know when someone's like
like that steve carrell joke where
that cheesy joke where you like go
behind the desk and you look like you're
going down steps
yeah like there was no desk or nothing
to
to block the view of you but as i looked
at your head it seemed as if you were
going
descending in a quicksand but really you
were just slowly like taking a knee
and then i'm pretty sure that christy
was the one who kind of caught you
it's a stone floor i could have really
like you were just totally flipped you
were gone
and yeah i'll have to ask christy but
i'm pretty sure she's the one who like
caught you and made sure you didn't hit
your head well because she's very
fixated
after she hit her head you know three
and a half years ago
uh people not hitting their head and no
one else had the gumption to move
no one else reacted and then and then we
were like it was silence
like you you were just she was like she
was like under your weight
and then like she like put you down
and kristy was the only one with any
sense like no one else
no one was reacting well she did a
really good job she like she was like
go get a wet towel uh he's fainted well
you know and you they gotta wet you were
out for a while
because they went got a wet tile towel
rung it out
brought it back over and then handed it
to christy and then christy's like
it just it was very weird from my
perspective because i mean it's not it's
not like
i mean i don't see her ever dabbing your
face with a wet towel that's just not
the nature of your relationship it's
only happened a couple of times it's not
the nature of your relationship right
so it's like it's like there's my wife
caring for my best friend
like she would a baby yeah i mean i was
as helpless as a baby and i
felt so it was very weird i was as
helpless
well the funny thing is is it i don't
know if you came too
and you could not make sense of what had
happened i don't you were embarrassed
this happens to you um
and i don't know if it's my height or
some underlying i'm sure i'm gonna get
internet diagnosed which happens all the
time um hashtag your biscuits
but i for my entire life if i'm like
kneeling down for an extended period of
time and i get up too quickly like i'll
have to like hold myself up against the
the blood's got a long way to go to get
back to that walnut brainy
and i thought that that's what was
happening because i can remember
that feeling and i was like oh it's one
of those things where and this also
happened like
uh when i hurt my knee earlier this year
uh skiing
and like we said well i was sitting at
the
dinner table we were talking about it
and i and again i started thinking i
started i was like i gotta go to the
bathroom and like splash my water with
my face with water and on the way to the
bathroom i started feeling it happening
it's like oh no i'm gonna
i'm gonna faint in this restaurant but i
like held myself up you better be
holding on to stuff
yeah and i i mean i usually do it's just
that scenario there was nothing to hold
on except there was nothing yeah there
was nothing yeah
and of course my feigning story of when
like i was
christmas time i was opening the barbie
yeah that uh at my in-laws house that my
daughter got on christmas morning
my father-in-law gave me his
knife out of his pocket and i cut open
the
barbie plastic shell and i cut my finger
immediately panicked ran out of the room
ran into the kitchen put my finger under
the kitchen
sink i don't know why you want to run
water over it for some reason
and um next thing i knew
the the the iris was opening up all i
could see was my father-in-law's face
and i
he i was in his arms yeah and that is
not the nature of our relationship
you don't have any like immediate energy
to be like
oh well i i'm sorry it's just you're
just a baby you're just like
like you can't say anything it's almost
like a rebirth
it's like i was reborn
you know you go through the whole
process of like learning to speak again
and learning to walk but so it is scary
i mean
it's i it there's a spooky element to it
because you've lost
time and then you're being immediately
ridiculed
in both of our cases like i we felt so
bad but we didn't make fun of you to
your face we went you went to bed and we
were like dang that was weird
uh nicola marbra
at nick the chick tweeted at us i got
chased by
beavers one night in an or propelled
john boat okay she was just by the power
of rowing she was trying to escape
beavers it was pitch black and i had to
alternate rowing and shining a
flashlight while they randomly popped up
and smacked their tails on the water
darkness plus water plus being chased by
an unseen
loud creature equals scary beavers
know the power that they they hold
um i know we got into a little bit of a
disagreement at one point about how big
beavers are
um and uh beavers are
bigger than what was my position on the
beaver you were like whole
you were like saying beavers were like
this tall like i remember like you
holding your hands
i don't remember yeah light was on just
like 14 inches tall and i was like
beavers can be like
three feet tall and you were like no way
like i think a beaver i think a beaver
yeah without that and again i'm gonna
tell you it can be that big i'm gonna
tell you again you're still talking
about a capybara
no i'm talking look up picture look up
beavers how to i'm just going to look
out how tall
is a big beaver the average
well i want to know the upper upper
range how tall is the average beaver
no internet let me turn the internet on
35 to 65
pounds uh heaviest on record is 110
pounds they are three to four
feet long and stand one to one and a
half feet tall
one to one and a half that's the average
man that's the average
okay like so so the picture of big
beaver
okay big beaver can i use your laptop
big beaver all right i'm just searching
big beaver
and i'm going to images yeah i mean you
got safe search on
oh good god yeah like that this guy okay
so there's people hold
there's a big burly man holding up a
beaver by the hind legs
and you see the tail is only that big
but look how i mean look at that
so the so the hips are at his nips
and his in the nose is at the shin and i
bet that guy's at least four
four foot tall they've got to be a big
beaver before they get the courage to
come after you
to haunt you like that and especially
when you're on a boat that's being
propelled by
wooden oars you're especially it's like
you're propelling the boat with the
thing they love to eat you know why
nona's got herself a big brown beaver
and she strokes it all the time yep
um let's get to the real ghosts i'm
tired i'm tired of this beating around
the
bush okay the beavers
all right have at it man use your spooky
voice this is from
sasa sasa the vilbor
the evil bear the evil bear that makes a
lot more sense
my biggest scare is more spiritual
when i was 12 i was alone at home and i
saw that on my bed
was a dip like someone was sitting on
the bed
when i did a double take i saw the tip
lift no the dip lift is what she meant
to write
i saw the dip lift like when someone
stands up
i hid in the living room
[Music]
hashtag your biscuit okay that's that's
kind of mild i mean you might be a fault
you saw a divot
in your mattress that then plumpified
at age 12 yeah age 12 how reliable are
you at age 12
i mean just just just talking hormones
alone
like if a 12 year old reporter came to
you
i mean first of all does he have a hat
does it say press no
no one trusts the media anymore anyway
much less a 12 year old reporter
so 12 year old reporter comes up and
there's just i believe the
children journalists are our future
aliens
landed in belarus you'd be like
okay prove it 12 year old i think sasa
i think you got to you got to be looking
for spooky things in order to see
something like that
i don't think because that's not an
attention-grabbing thing it's not a
cupboard slamming
you know it's not it's not someone
like a possessed person yelling at you
that normally loves you i don't know
i mean listen i don't do i don't i don't
discount it i just think it's
but i think it's bit nitpicky oh and to
make it clear i mean
we're not trying to pick these apart
even though we just did with that one
uh i'm open to this i just don't i think
you have to be looking for something to
spook you to see something that
that's subtle yeah well you know how big
the dip was i mean what if this was a
thick ghost um you know it depends on
how big the
how much the bed is being deformed like
if i'm in a certain mindset
anything can scare me like when you make
me watch the scary movies
and then for the next week or so as i've
said before i ain't ashamed to say it
i get scared taken out of the trash i
mean there's like a there's a dark area
where the trash can should go i also get
scared not necessarily taking the trash
out
uh i have to run i take the trash out
and then i kind of run back but like i
told you
when i'm by myself in the woods i get
scared and it is because of all the
the things that i put into my mind with
horror movies and
horror books but i won't i can't stop
though
the thing that happened to me in my
camping trip is not something that i
you know i to a fault i wasn't ready
for something spooky to happen yeah
that's because i made it clear with
people's reactions
yeah to your story of you not going
outside
when your wife was offered well was
asked about hot dogs at golden cheesy
william miyad tweeted
spooky voice when i was nine or ten
already we don't remember what age we
were
no oh when i was nine and ten let's say
that
we moved into a funeral home as part of
the family business
i started to have persistent sleep
paralysis
and saw a figure both in the room when
awake
and in the elevator in my dreams
those two years were probably the
scariest in my life
they stopped after moving okay so
funeral homes man at 10 years old okay
there's three things
it's a funeral home with a freaking
elevator in it and you're living in it
you're living in a freaking funeral home
it's part of the family business
wild sleep paralysis i mean the only
thing scarier than sleep paralysis
is like surgery paralysis and i don't
even want to talk about that
all right i know you're you're related
you're afraid of sleep paralysis because
you feel like you've had it at times
right well
that was yeah i know it's an interesting
way to put that
you're afraid of sleep paralysis because
you feel like you've had it
i didn't say i said because you've had
it no you said you feel like you
did i say this okay i have had it but i
i have not had it in probably 10 or 15
years
i had it a lot as a kid and i and it
slowly wore
off in my 20s and i haven't had it in
many years uh
but a lot of people report seeing so
when you have paralysis you can see with
your eye your eyes are open
not for me so okay for william saw a
figure
in the room most people in awake
but in sleep paralysis most people sense
the presence of a figure
like what happens is you your mind wakes
up but your body
does not and so you can you're so you're
fully aware
i'm in my bed and what happened with me
i would wake up and i would be like
oh no it's happening again i can feel
myself
in my bed i can feel the position that
i'm in
and i can't move my i can't open my eyes
i can't do
anything and so you really so you're
faced with a choice now you could be
like i'm just going to lay here and go
back to sleep
but for me i could never do that i had
to
commit fully to getting out of it so i
would like start
trying to find a limb to move and you
would be like and eventually you like go
like
and then you get out of it what that
would happen to me pretty often growing
up like breaking out of a shell or
something
but some people when they wake up and
they're in that state they will sense
the presence it's very common
there's a name for the for the person
the ghost it's like a dark figure
that they sense when they're slenderman
and sleep paralysis
slender man may be based on this
character but it's just this dark figure
um i've heard many people talk about it
i never i never saw the dark
figure sleep paralysis
common figures
people who experienced sleep paralysis
have essentially woken up before they
stopped dreaming it's an incredibly
common sleep problem and estimated eight
percent of people who experience it
regularly
um ever wake up frozen in the middle of
the night
what see and see a pitch black figure
yeah okay here it is imagine you're
asleep and you suddenly open your eyes
this is
kqed.org science
your body won't move if this is
something's holding you down you hear
scratching in the corner of the room
then see a pitch black figure you think
it's just your mind playing tricks until
the figure starts moving
slowly it's getting closer you shut your
eyes but you can hear it shuffling
toward you
this is what sleep paralysis is like not
for me
sleep paralysis usually occurs when
you're well asleep
your brain is telling you to go to sleep
and to not move because when you walk
around in your sleep that's not good but
some people have a problem with
that not turning off so when they wake
up they still can't move
oh gosh and people who are susceptible
to sleep paralysis
if i'm if i remember correctly are more
likely
to have the surgery paralysis thing
happen oh my gosh that is a nightmare
william i'm sorry that happened to you
living in a funeral home
oh my gosh and then dreaming about the
same person
once you've seen something that freaks
you out dreaming about it i guess makes
sense well you know
it could just be so i told this story on
gmm
years ago about my wife and i having
a shared dream well in my dream
specifically
and you can go back to the gmm because
it was much more fresh and i told it the
very next day but
essentially what i dreamed is that i was
in this elevator and the elevator opened
and there was this little
blonde girl who was had evil intent of
some kind and it was very scary and i
woke up
and i started talking to jesse about it
and she had just had
a dream at the same time about a little
blonde girl
and we were kind of just like what did i
say and we just sat there in in
in the bed kind of freaking out for a
while well
uh at jade underscore jim reg
tweeted me and my family were talking
about spooky ghost stuff and i said how
i've seen a girl with long hair and a
long white nightgown run by my line of
vision out of the corner of my eye
and then my whole family starts sharing
stories from when they've seen the same
ghost
with the same descriptions
having other people experience the same
thing either in a dream or like i mean
if you trust somebody who also sees
the same thing you saw then that makes
you feel a little less crazy but a lot
more scared
and i got to you know kiko
is our producer editor of your biscuits
he's sitting in that behind that glass
in the other room right now
um you know he rolled up all of these uh
all these responses that that that you
gave to us but then he said and you know
what
i actually have a story uh if you want
to talk about it you can
and uh he wrote it down i'm gonna read
it and then i asked kiko to get on the
mic so that we could ask some follow-up
questions because
you know i've never seen a ghost i
haven't either
i have not been looking
so maybe that's my problem well i don't
know but let me read kiko's story
though though we've never seen ghosts we
do have people in our lives
over the years who would tell these
compelling stories and they would have
no reason to lie to us we have every
reason to believe them
kiko absolutely being one of them yeah
someone who according to their story
they honestly saw something they
believed to be
supernatural here's kiko's story uh even
though he goes over there i'm just going
to read his story since it's here and
you know i'm a control freak we've
established yes i lived in an old house
in glendale for a few years
almost a decade ago i was home alone
when all of a sudden out of nowhere i
started feeling
ice cold rage for absolutely no reason
if i could describe it it physically
felt like my blood was turning to ice
and my body felt like it was about to
explode
this is completely abnormal for me
because i'm actually a mellow person
well we can vouch for that yes
kiko is very true is extremely mellow
i decided to go to bed and i was in this
weird half awake
half a sleep state where i was aware of
my friend
and then maggie who is who also works
also works with mythical yep
um so we know both of them so first of
all
it seems like kiko's describing like a
sleep paralysis situation um
i was aware of maggie entering my room
at like
3 a.m because she was staying with me at
the time but i couldn't wake up
instead i was dreaming that i was on top
of this hill with
autumnal leaves oh listen that's a nice
adjective
but something was falling from the sky
when i climbed up to get a closer look
there was an
angel descending but it had
black matted hair a black toga
and black wings with holes punched all
over it
i also heard from back in the real world
the sound of something running around
but i figured it was my roommate's dog
that's all i remember from the night but
according to
my friend maggie i was convulsing
violently in my sleep when she entered
the room
the convulsions gradually got more and
more violent until i slammed the wall
with my fist
and my body suddenly became stiff
imagine maggie and i guess yeah maggie's
so we talk about
laid-back maggie's so quiet so quiet in
fact that she decided not to wake kiko
up i was like oh
he punched the wall but he's asleep now
it's 3 a.m i'm
gonna leave him be
continuing kiko's account i spoke with
my roommate
the next morning at the gym and
apparently he was staying in the
basement with his twin sister
who was visiting that night so talk
about now we got a twin involved this is
getting really spooky
so his roommate's downstairs with the
with with the twin
maggie's upstairs at 3 a.m seeing kiko
convulsing
um when the twin came downstairs
uh she said she saw
kiko's roommate trying to climb the wall
aggressively oh gosh oh gosh
oh gosh when she asked what he was doing
he flipped around and violently started
screaming at her
he had never yelled at her in his entire
life
when she cried for him to stop he calmed
down
but he doesn't remember any of this his
sister
twin sister had to fill him in on it the
next morning before he went to the gym
to tell kiko what had happened now i
once found you
in the middle of the night when you came
to sleep at my house yeah
and the uh when we were kids
just to clarify we were children at the
time
and uh we were staying in what we call
the extra room
yeah and i woke up to the sound of
scratching and you were standing up
next to the door like there's the door
and then there's the wall next to the
door and you were
next to the door on the wall and you
were just kind of going
like kind of scratching the wall like
you were trying to get out but you
couldn't find the door
pretty scary that's scary that's like
that's if i turned around and would have
yelled at you like the twin
it's like the end of the blair witch
project where there's like the dude like
just standing
facing away oh i haven't seen it you
know it like
but for some reason i knew you were
sleepwalking so it didn't really scare
the story's not over
yeah so kiko's roommate tells kiko what
ha
what his twin told him
before he got to the gym so
when we returned from the gym his twin
sister repeated the story and mentioned
she had heard something running around
on the first
floor i told her i had heard that too
but i thought it was a dog
according to her the dog was in the
basement with them the entire time
the roommate rushes down to the basement
no
my roommate then rushes down to the
basement because he said he forgot his
phone down there from last night
a split second later he runs back up the
stairs
literally crying telling us not
to go down the stairs he describes a
tall lanky thing that was
crouched in the fireplace oh gosh
it wasn't me i fit the description but
it wasn't me
when all three of us went down first of
all all three of them did go down yeah
yeah it's like a horror movie when all
three of us went down there was nothing
there
at the time i didn't mention my dream
because i thought it was stupid and
probably irrelevant
but a year later after many more
occurrences we were talking about that
initial incident at a pool party
it's then that i told him about my dream
and the dark angel figure floating down
from the sky with the holes in the wings
his face goes pale and he starts to
freak out
when i ask what's wrong his response was
that thing you described falling from
the sky
sounds exactly like the thing i saw in
the fireplace of the basement the next
morning
[Music]
glendale get on the mic man
yeah all right is this true man this is
true
every bit it is no embellishment no
embellishment every bit of it
to my memory now when you say throughout
the years there were many more things
that happened
such as my roommate seeing figures and
shadows random objects moving around
doors closing to top it all off my
roommate seeing a copy of me walking
around the house when i was in the
living room
okay so how i mean how how long did you
stick around
uh way longer than we should have two
years
so so you you were convinced that this
place was haunted
or how did you what did you come to
believe and then how did you
how did you go on living there like what
did you practically do
did you start talking to the demon so i
asked one of my friends who was
religious after this stuff happened
the first few incidents and he was like
oh do you have anything
voodoo in your house and i actually did
my friend had gone to new orleans and
brought back this like little
set of mini figurines i think you're
supposed to put them by your bed to for
them to take away
nightmares but he was like oh i would
get rid of those
just in case and i did and everything
that happened afterwards
except for the copy of me walking around
the house uh
it wasn't really malicious it was just
like oh hey i'm here i'm gonna open this
uh double folded door really slowly that
a wind can't do and you know
stuff like that so you're but but
you're your your roommate who's a twin
twins are so creepy man um i mean
literally came up the stairs crying i
mean there was no doubt in here even
though you didn't see the creature
except in your dream
there was and you had you know you
didn't you didn't share
the description until a year later
because there was there
so there was no way that your experience
even though it
mirror it it reflected his had anything
to do with it
right i mean but
you could tell just by the terror on his
face that that there was
that it was that was true yeah why did
you go down there you're like when all
three of us went down there it was gone
well when when he first came up i
thought he was joking to be honest
because he kind of has a morbid sense of
humor he's the type of person that would
be unplugging something and then
convulse
as if he got electrocuted yeah so uh i
didn't believe him at first but then
when i saw like
actual tears running down his face it's
like well
like i kind of want to check it out but
i was also scared so i actually have a
samurai sword in my room
so i took the samurai sword and brought
it downstairs you know those ghosts
um that is just weird so going into it
did you like what was your level of
openness
about supernatural things going into it
living there it's you know i there was
one
other thing that happened previously to
me where it was like oh it could be
just me or it could be maybe something
more but it wasn't enough for me to make
me believe in supernatural stuff
um i guess i guess i'm kind of i was
just kind of open to it but nothing
that drastic had ever happened before i
mean i'm
i'm i believe you and i believe i mean
we've got other close friends who've had
like
super creepy your hair looks like george
jones right now like
all of a sudden yeah i'm talking about
something creepy no like i
it looks good oh it does like you looked
at me and you had the headphones on and
your hair i was like it's starting to
look like you think i think you could do
do you i know you think like cutting it
you need to before you cut it
see if you can style it exactly like
george jones because it's
like pompadour it out and it's like
getting a little bit gray
i think you might have something here
sorry you're clearly not
creeped out by this story but i
appreciate the compliment
i knew you would well i'm trying to
think of a george jones song this thing
uh what's what's the there's someone's
about ghosts he got some stuff about
ghosts
uh there's one about a picture
uh never mind anyway um
so you thought i mean you think this is
a demon i mean you were climbing you
were fighting something
and then he was freaking climbing the
walls and like yelling the fact that you
had this shared
like hysterical moment in the middle of
the night
yeah um and also to the whole his twin
sister seeing it and then maggie seeing
it because they would have
no reason to make that stuff up right
like maggie seeing you freaking out and
then at the same time
the sister seeing him freaking out
downstairs you were responding
this demon came down you know it was
shot up by like angels with like a
like a shotgun like it was it had bullet
holes riddled through its
angel buck shot yeah angle angel butt
shot can't you say it you think angel's
got shotguns and then it came down your
chimney dude
yeah that's what happened let's let's
back up a little bit
okay so i'm just because i'm gonna try
to i'm just gonna try to imagine
so if you go back to like go back to
like the the way i was raised
in like my sort of ideology belief
system worldview growing up and that was
uh you can say we were raised we were
raised yeah
evangelical christianity and a
particular strain of evangelical
christianity
so not like the charismatic where
there's like
uh you know you've got like pentecostal
we didn't believe in angels and demons
interacting with humans well no we did
but we didn't really
we believed in the biblical accounts of
it happening in the past
and we believed that it was possible but
we believe that it did there was no need
for it
well that may be specifically what you
what you thought
like but i didn't you're talking about
like the dispensations
and i but i didn't think that
supernatural things didn't happen
and like when i heard like you know
catholic priests
talking about exorcisms or like
pentecostal pastors talking about
exorcisms
i was like this is probably not real
even as someone who
subscribed to a quote unquote
supernatural worldview and believed that
these things were real
i just didn't think that they were
happening at that frequency
and you know and so i didn't find myself
getting scared and but
but also based on
the particulars like interpretation of
the bible
that we had we didn't believe in ghosts
like absent from the body present with
the father right so
there is you're either alive and your
spirit is inside of you or your spirit
is
gone to you know heaven or hell what i
mean just
it's a little more complicated than that
but it's not like you got ghosts going
around right
so like we thought the whole idea of
ghosts was like well
if there's any ghost activity yeah this
is actually demonic activity this is
you know satan and the fallen angels
now again i could i had this
intellectual
understanding of this stuff but i didn't
i didn't really i mean i guess i could i
guess if you press me i would say i
believe it but
i never experienced anything that i
would attribute to
this demonic activity however i had many
good friends uh people i was very close
to who had had
really convincing supernatural
experiences
most often in like other cultures and
other places like oh i was a missionary
in africa or
missionary in the caribbean or whatever
and so
you're going to a place where there's
like a different sort of spiritual
energy and then they would have these
stories about
people growing fangs and you know i mean
and i do not believe that they were
making it up i do not believe that they
were lying to me
but there was always a part of me and
regardless of how reliable i thought the
person was
that was just like yeah but there's
probably they're deceived because that's
probably a natural explanation for this
that doesn't mean that they're dishonest
but it means that like you know our
brains are kind of wired to see
things and to interpret things in ways
that might not necessarily represent
reality and i mean that's been proven
that your brain
and the way your eyes send the messages
to your brain like
you're not really seeing reality you're
seeing a projection or
a a representation of reality right and
things can kind of get screwed up but
when it
so but so i'm i'm saying the way that i
used to think about it
and bought out it was nice to think that
and but now i like to go back there
now it's kind of like just dismiss it
all i don't have a
because i'm in a place in my life from a
spiritual perspective where i don't have
a i i don't believe that certainty about
this kind of thing is possible i just
sort of have this sort of like
openness to hear people talk about it
and be like
wow i ca i don't know what happened and
i feel like me trying to explain it
is just gonna do a disservice to your
experience it doesn't help that there's
a lot
of people out there who are preying on
people's hopes of connecting with the
their loved ones who've gone who've died
who've gone on to the afterlife or maybe
are lingering by their claims you know
it's there's a lot
there's a lot of quacks who've been
disproven well what do you think i
actually went back and watched
like the pin and teller show [ __ ]
and
they had an episode on psychic readings
and like
uh accessing people from the dead and
they basically debunked
a couple of people and then it
draws into question the whole thing but
like there's like
all of these independent variables that
all point to the same
independent corroboration you know
starts to make it quite a head scratcher
and like you're upstairs having this
experience i'm downstairs having this
experience
but if it was just i saw a figure in the
fireplace it's like well i you know i've
you know i've seen a long-nosed man in
my own poop
you know it's yeah you can that's a
little different a long-nosed man
yeah um is that a saying that you just
came up with
yeah did it sound like it it sounded
like a fable it could be like an old
saying yeah that's it you've seen it
along along those men in your own poop
that's that's what makes me worth
listening to
you listen to me and you think you're
listening to a fable the question
the question is if these things are oh i
just got
freaking spooked yeah because it's in
your mind now
i don't know if you watch the video it's
important literally
i just got spooked i thought i heard
something mm-hmm
it was my feet moving under the table it
was and it bounced off the wall and you
turned around and got freaked out
because it was in your mind
and it and now i'm scared and i have a
little bit of a headache but okay
but answer me this or try let's talk
about this
if these you know
again it's it's so interesting to think
about because
first of all i don't want to talk about
this anymore if you think about tonight
when i'm
hold on just let me finish the thought
um if you think about supernatural
things
you know there's a lot of people who
have a perspective that what does that
even mean
supernatural means like beyond natural
right
so if so we're it seems like what the
implication is is that there's something
that
is beyond the observable world right
but a non-physical realm but
why does whatever that is and whatever
people are experiencing
why is that supernatural why isn't why
isn't it not just the case that
it's all natural it's all within our
experience it's just there's certain
things that we don't yet
understand and can't yet explain like we
have not developed the
the capacity you go back just a couple
hundred years
go back a hundred years and if i were to
tell you
that there are literally trillions of
little creatures
all over you right now you think i was
nuts
right yeah i'd be like right around your
eyes especially there's a bunch of
crazy little creatures that if i were to
if i were to draw a picture of what this
creature looks like you would be like
he's a demon
right but it's just bacteria right
and so and now we have the ability to
see it
we figured out how to make things really
magnified and we can now see
when i look at you i don't see anything
i can get as close as i want to to your
face i don't see anything
but if i have the right tools to measure
it and to observe it
i would be totally freaked out by what's
on your face right now
and so my question is is it just that
we've been experiencing these hints
of something that is outside not of uh
our out it's not outside of the natural
world but it's just
outside of our ability to comprehension
and understand at the current time
except in certain instances where they
slip up and and
and cross over to our realm and it is
freaky
but again you go back to pre
any discovery and i would if i were to
tell you these things
it would freak you out right so to me
it's a little bit more comforting when i
think like when i think about it in
terms of
like i have to put it into some sort of
established
system or world view like this is evil
and this is good these are demons these
are angels these are ghosts
it's just like okay it's okay
if i'm betting i'm saying that if i had
to bet
i would say yes there is something that
is actually being experienced
that is not just limited to some sort of
perception issue in someone's mind
kiko are you rhett said
he's having a bet here but what is your
what is your percent confidence
that there is a
however you would describe it a
supernatural
realm a spiritual realm
um how percent confident am i yeah
after those couple of experiences those
few years
uh i mean it's pretty high
like i would say at least eighty percent
just because
it wasn't just okay so you still got 20
yeah there's still some doubt
there's this i i feel like i'm always
gonna have a little bit of doubt
but there's just because it i i told the
story of me and my roommate but
we actually had up to nine people living
in that house at one time
uh because it was a three-story house
commune i get it and
um out of those nine people at least
seven had something happened to them
um and a bunch of those people actually
didn't believe
in supernatural stuff at all when they
first came in like they
they knew our story uh because we were
one of the first ones to move in but
they just didn't really
believe it um so yeah i would i would
say
like 80 percent if you would have gone
downstairs and seen
dude i'm calling it a demon do you call
it a demon
sure i'm not asking you i just happen to
be looking at you
yeah demon okay yeah if you would have
seen it
crouched when you went down there you'd
probably be at 100
right yeah absolutely right because your
experience was
you saw it in the dream and then you saw
other things like uh doors somebody else
saw it in real life
windows heard things heard things moving
around yeah it was um
and a couple of roommates saw like a a
man kind of floating
uh from one room to the next and maggie
actually had a story
where like the champ she was taking a
shower in my shower
uh and the shampoo bottle kind of
started swaying all of a sudden
not an earthquake just randomly one
shampoo bottle started swaying
and she ran out and the dog came
bursting in and started barking and she
said you could see his
eye line going from the bathroom where
she was taking a shower
to uh the door that led out of my room
and then he calmed down
and see dogs bring a shower into this
kiko and here's the thing damn it i take
a shower every day pretty much
dogs yeah we have a window in your
shower that's not that seems
not freaky exit like for dogs and and
little children right before before you
develop
this like full consciousness which is
actually
you kind are turning some parts of your
consciousness off okay
you have the ability potentially i'm
just kind of going out on a limb here
right
this is what some people would say they
have the ability
because they aren't yet uh haven't yet
decided to tune certain things out in
the way that adults have
they have a they they have the ability
to perceive it they've got the
instrumentation
young kids and dogs
young kids and animals they can see this
stuff man
but okay what about clearly i have a
bias because i'm afraid
yeah you're saying you don't you don't
want it to be real because it freaks you
out
right um i'm just trying i'm just
legitimately asking the question like
okay what if it
what if this stuff is real and
we just don't we kind of we find ways to
like categorize it and we find ways to
explain it
what about the people who because
everyone who's like dedicated their
lives to being like
i'm gonna go out and i'm gonna try to
find scientific
evidence of this stuff right i mean sure
you've got your like ghost
people who have like the weird like
little meter that's like
measuring stuff i can't believe that
there's any sort of
electric i i wouldn't think that there
would actually be like an
electromagnetic signature for spiritual
activity
it feels like uh it feels like you're
going into
a situation and you're trying to like
smell
something that you could only feel you
know what i mean like you're using the
wrong
faculties to detect something i i
i don't know that's how i guess we know
though but it just feels like
it wouldn't surprise me neither either
option wouldn't surprise me if it's all
just weird things that happen in
people's minds
circumstantial and like you've got the
situation where like kiko says okay well
there were seven nine people living
there seven people experienced it
uh and these people didn't believe in
supernatural things but yet but they did
know they were moving into a house where
other
people had seen things and so all now
all of a sudden your mind is like
attuned to it just like you thought you
saw something over your shoulder a
second ago because we're talking about
this did the room
happen who was um
dreaming and climbing up the wall and
yelling at his twin sister
did he describe his dream does his dream
have anything to do with this demon
um no he actually doesn't remember
anything
um yeah his sister just filled him in on
everything but yeah he doesn't remember
dreaming about anything at all that's
that's powerful okay well here's another
key you're fired yeah you can't be
around anymore
i know you want to move on because you
can tell you're scared yeah i'm but i'm
going to make you i'm going to make you
stick with this
we're going to find a new um kiko
if you okay you said you didn't want
this to be true
right i understand that i don't really
have
a position i don't think i just want to
know if it's true
but let's just say that you experience
something
like maybe like okay uh me and you go on
a camping trip
and it gets dark and then
we light the fire and all of a sudden
like you're kind of
having a conversation with me and then
the next thing you know
i just literally start floating
in the air and i float above you
and then i start going in circles around
you and then when i open my mouth
what's your tongue like uh a forked it's
a fork tongue
start speaking in a different language
it sounds like it might be latin but you
don't know you didn't take a lot neither
did i
so but you're like he certainly sounds
like he's speaking some english words
are from latin yeah i can discover a few
root words
and so maybe there's some meaning in it
and then i go and i like get into the
fire and i like
put my face into the fire and my flesh
melts off of my face and it's just my
skeleton
keep in mind i'm still speaking in latin
and then i reach down and i pick
the pieces of melted flesh out of the
fire
and i put them back on my face and like
puzzle
still speaking latin it all comes
together i float back
sit down in my camp chair my rei fold
out camp chair
and then all of a sudden
i go completely back to normal so that
would be difficult to like deny right
well
if that exact scenario happened now what
would happen in your
your world view would be affected in
what way
well if that were to happen christy
would know what to do
go get a wet rag i want you to seriously
answer the question
like what would you say change
everything what would you it would
no it wouldn't change change everything
well no what would believe i would
believe what
i would believe that i believe it all
man
i'd believe it all but what does that
mean that i would be afraid to go
camping again
i mean it's again it's like it's uh
i don't i mean you and you revel in like
it's entertaining for you to be scared
but like this is getting too real for me
no
no but that's not that i know that it
scares you
because i'm saying that that's what it
would do to me it might
it might paralyze me
socially emotionally it would be it
would be
trauma but would you think it was like a
message from god
that you're that you've strayed that
you're that you're your best friend is
being is
being led by a demon now if you had a
message
in english that i could understand that
would be something to reckon with
hmm okay i'll make sure i have a message
before you put your melted face back
when this happens
i guess the reason i'm asking the
question is because you don't you're
playing you see
you're you're a child playing with fi
firecrackers
you don't you don't know what real
explosives are like
and if you ever if you ever went through
what
kiko or his his his roommate twin went
through
you wouldn't be so light-hearted about
this i actually have a
sober view this is a coping mechanism
yeah i
it is a mechanism but i'm one could
argue
that i'm much more like a believer than
you are
my coping mechanism is to make it funny
exactly
you're just as afraid as me i didn't say
i wasn't afraid
i just said i like being afraid but you
like i hate it i like you like being
afraid knowing that it's not real in the
back of the back of the back of your
mind
no no but if you knowing that it might
be real it's the only reason i'm scared
the moment i'm
those moments when i'm like hold on
aliens could exist like i get
that that makes my stomach drop like
anything that's like that
cataclysmically groundbreaking but what
is it
what what is what is scaring you in that
moment because aliens
not you're right it doesn't uh honestly
i demon stuff that's why i said it
scares me don't like those movies
i do like those movies i love them and i
hate them at the same time and the
reason i hate them is because
i can easily buy into it right there's a
lot of people who watch that stuff and
they're like i know this isn't real but
like
i i don't to but you're simulating
something that if it was really
happening
i think you might it might damage you i
think it would damage you
well i'm not that's not the question i'm
interested in is what it would
what i would think after it right i'm
just saying it's like i don't i don't
plenty of people believe
they actually seem fine actually you
know there's
i mean kiko's 80 he's pretty cool
that's not what i'm he's healthy i'm i'm
not saying
any either way would be good or bad i'm
not i'm i'm trying to answer your
question i just
i'm just trying to figure out what i
would think because there was a there
was a time in which
if i saw something i'm saying i would
there's plenty of people who do believe
that
let's look at what they think and it's
like that actually gives me hope that
like
well they believe all kinds of different
things yeah i mean they're i guess is
what i'm saying
because some people would file it some
people experience something and they
have to file it into
a pre-existing ideology all right and
there was a bit there's a big portion of
my life
especially like as i was kind of coming
out of christianity
whereas if i experienced something
definitively supernatural
it would have been the tipping point to
thrust me back into
traditional christian faith now if i
experience something like that
i think that the conclusion i would come
to is oh
that stuff happens
i don't know what exactly what it means
but i wouldn't necessarily be like oh i
need to orient it into
a belief system you know what i'm saying
like i don't feel that i
i don't know that's why i was asking the
question
it i think it would make me feel like i
i needed to
make sense of it i needed to more
aggressively pursue some sort of belief
system
that's right i think it would it would
drive me
to a more aggressive quest for
nailing down some some beliefs otherwise
i've been pretty comfortable just kind
of
floating floating on love but the
chances are if
either of us experience something it's
going to be in this
sort of ambiguous category where you can
just make it
you've already made up your mind that's
where faith comes in
because you because you could experience
something and like
you could take it at face value or you
could just write it off and say that was
only in my mind
and you probably have made the decision
before the experience
right or the decision was made for you
by the
by the one that possesses you which we
call
fate but others call demons i don't know
i believe you kiko i believe you too
80 i mean if you're not he's not even
100
it was never it was never on the table
whether i believed him
or believe we have another really good
friend who's seen
a lot of stuff yeah i do not have
any doubt that he has experienced the
things
that he says he has experienced the
question is what is it
and that's where i'm just like i don't
know and even if i experience the exact
same things i don't think i would be
like oh
i know now i think i'd just be more
confused
but i kind of do think it would be cool
for it to happen
until it does no i hope i'm not there
nope
no i hope you are there because think
about the episode of your biscuits that
we get out of it yeah
if we're both there that will be a
redemptive quality to the experience
i mean like you know how britain goes
off and he and he he doesn't just go to
haunted houses like britain goes to the
historically
haunted places like the most haunted
places back when you could travel
he would go to these places spend the
night at a place that had a reputation
for being haunted like he's trying to
get to the bottom of it and i really
like that i really respect that
like i would love i don't think he's
investigating i think he's just
he's in it for the thrill the thrill of
it yeah but and i'm saying that
i totally get that like it's yeah
i understand that until you're saying
until it happens at that point i'd be
like oh i this was a mistake is that
what you think would happen yes
yeah i i think i would because that's
being real scary i think what would
happen
is i would be like this is super scary
and this is exactly what i was after
like when you got really scared in the
haunted mazes you would applaud like an
old man
the reason i applaud like an old man is
because i am an old man
and the reason i applaud especially when
we went through the uh the uh
us us maze is it was so well done and
i'm like
so scared like with the this
jumps in your face it scares you and you
applaud well here's the thing when you
go to these haunted houses
you're going to do that to a real ghost
i don't think you will no
precisely exactly precisely you need a
bigger fix
the reason i'm clapping is because i'm
like you brought me to the verge
of peeing on myself like i bravo you
know what i'm saying i'm like yes this
is great yes daddy is happy
but daddy knows that this is fake but
when daddy doesn't know that it's fake
daddy's not gonna be clapping daddy's
gonna be crappy
and i'm saying i don't want something to
make me clap i want something to make me
crap man
kiko thanks for sharing your story uh
kiko you got to give us that address
so we can go check it out yeah after the
podcast for sure
i'm sure man
if you've seen a ghost you're like i
don't know how you feel about what you
got you get
outside you're getting so uncomfortable
the past like 20 minutes you've been
really uncomfortable like ever since you
saw that thing
i didn't see it i thought i saw this
think about it man we could go get to a
haunted house
think about how fun it would be like
it's fun for you to get scared like this
one for me
isn't that fun for you
you're not gonna answer me okay i have a
wreck
uh that's all you know in the same vein
but a totally different direction
that's called an artery um
a movie that you should watch if you
want to get yourself
in the halloween spirit it's almost too
late but you don't want to be scared and
listen oh yes
i know the the video of this is coming
out after halloween but yeah i mean
i still i mean it's just just removed
from it hocus pocus
watched that with the family the other
night and the reason i watched it is
because
stevie has talked about this movie quite
often in fact
uh tobias
a friend of ours who was dylan in buddy
system
uh who's an incredible actor who's been
in a bunch of things
his first gig as a teenager was
playing like the high school bully in
hocus pocus
and when he came to audition for the
role of dylan
stevie was like where did i recognize
this guy's face from and it was hocus
pocus
i'd never seen it jesse was like let's
watch hocus pocus and i've never seen it
and you know you we were too old for it
you got to know what you're getting into
you're getting into a 1993
disney movie starring bette midler and
sarah jessica parker as
witches and the i can't remember the
third actor's name but
um it's it's ridiculous there's musical
numbers
um you're kind of laughing
at the 90s as you enjoy it but
you have to go into it with that level
of expectation that
you're you're laughing at this did
shepherd like it yeah
he did yeah but he he liked it on a
a cynical level we we watched those
kinds of like he gets a kick out of
watching things that were kind of come
from the era of when
we were his age or close to it so
you go in with that kind of expectation
not like this is some like
yeah classic movie that's going to hold
up i mean it's like 37 on rotten
tomatoes it's not
you know a critically acclaimed movie
he's he's 12 years old
it's a it's does he have his press
credentials well
he could be a reporter yeah i'll send
him to i'll send you know i'm going to
send shepard to this address in glendale
uh with a notepad have him do a little
report a hat with a
press card in it hocus pocus watch it
hashtag gear biscuits we'll talk at you
next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best